ciao ragazzi bentornati sanità stories
cercate di fare silenzio anche voi
questa nuova challenge
dobbiamo cercare di rubare tutti i
biscotti a granny senza svegliarla
praticamente rimini sta dormendo sul
divano ea il vassoio con tutti i
biscotti in grembo a turno io e vitale
dovremmo cercare di rubarle più biscotti
possibile e vince alla fine chi avrà più
biscotti quando gremi si speri non
potremo più continuare a rubare i
biscotti anche quel clino dovrà cercare
di fare silenzio per un berlino pronti
per questa challenge secondo te chi
vincerà tra mete berlino secondo me
vinceti tale perché non vede l'ora di
prendere i biscotti ad allontanare tutti
quindi serviti a scoprirete se ho avuto
io ho vitale ma mi raccomando a di
silente anche poi in questo video c'è
nascosta nel mezzo del pd una parola
segreta
se riuscite a trovarla scrivetela qui
nei commenti
vediamo in quanti riuscite a trovarla
siete pronti
prendete le patatine con corna mettetevi
comodi
ecco che mi vedete
è quel che dorme berlino sta cercando di
rubare i biscotti ma così rischia di
svegliarlo già ora proverò a prendere un
biscotto chiaro piano
speriamo che non si svegli
[Musica]
seminato serata scappiamo i ragazzi mi
sono scossa perché in trend si è
svegliata mi fa cercando ma sono
riuscita a prendere due mi scotti era
quasi riuscito a prendere il tempo
capello il terzo dopo e si è sfasciata
ora a gravitare spero che non ci sta
bene
[Musica]
da bambino adesso abbiamo fatto un tour
roio giornalita adesso tocca trolley
allora non avete visto una prima vitale
ha barato perché mi ha preso due in una
volta ne va preso uno alla volta
[Musica]
finora ne ho solo tu e spero di
prendermi
di tutto di più
le crisi sollecitare nero qui sconto si
risponde
[Musica]
gli stessi tanto sopra che quindi non
può vedere un po solo sentivo quindi
saper fare senza parlare più
[Musica]
ok è andata via si sono riuscito a
prendere solo un disco biscotti
presentare a 3 biscotti quindi vitale in
vantaggio ma edizione vediamo come viva
questo turno
[Musica]
credi che pescato preso
non puoi mangiare il cioccolato giù di
forma le scappa tasche basco preso un
altro biscotto quasi numero 4 sono in
vantaggio rispetto a de mita
adesso toccherà a lei insomma
[Musica]
ho fatto ce l'ho fatta
c'è un po
sono miglior mai non po di prenderli i
remi primo maggio i biscotti non è la
bocca c'è alla bocca varazze
mi dispiace grain bimba non puoi
mangiare biscotti ma allora perché li
fai lo fai apposta per per farti di
rubare e poi rincorrere le persone
quelle nate proprio cattiva però mi devi
fare filotto perché tanto tempo puoi
mangiare detto che ci vuole è nascosto
di qua vuole parlarmi attimi ha rubato
un biscotto ma non riusciva a mangiarlo
ma no ero shader e andato a comprare gli
ingredienti molto legamenti scotti
quindi dovremo farne altri di questa
volta ha detto di par alla mela
o no berlino allora li corre a mangiare
tutti può pure stare alla mela
avvelenata di biancaneve paura fino a
rimangiare questi biscotti se li ha
fatti g secondo me no ma io comunque non
avevo allora contiamo quanti picco ti
abbiamo io ne ho pure o 2 3 4 5 6 mag di
e tv fatti io solo due come più lenta
perché domani tutto mangiare 4 va bene
il tubo di carote mia crisi da aspettare
nell'attesa meter mi nascondevo da
granny due sono spariti
vi sono caduti non è vero che li ho
mangiati sono caduti 4 stato mi piace su
questo video raggiunge i 40 mila mi
piace faremo la seconda parte a favore
fatelo per me quindi almeno posso
mangiare gli altri biscotti e se volete
potete decidere voi le regole di questo
gioco giorni comuni se volete dire al
kranich gusto fare i biscotti fatelo
sapere nei commenti così magari lì dove
del lido poi deciderà però mi sembra di
aver capito che è andato a comprare
quelli là alla mecca è data a comprare
gli ingredienti per fare quelle da me la
vedremo nel tour estivo il piccolo
quattro cartellini di cliccare per
vedere industry altri cliccate su quello
che preferite ma teme la mela